字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
中文字幕志愿者 李宗盛
字幕志愿者 李宗盛
大家晚安 大家晚安
有听到声音哦
有听到声音吗
听到的加个1啊
有听到声音加个1
加个1
喔 有聽到聲音加個音喔
欸 有有有 有聽到聲音
很小聲 把他弄近一點喔 弄近一點應該就比較大聲了
好
那一開始請各位加這幾個QR Code啦
這個是PB的九折優惠券
這Telg粉絲團
Light 觀眾社團 YouTube跟IG
那這個Telg粉絲團呢
會公告一些事項啦 觀眾社團有交易知識
Youtube教學影片,IG呢會PO一些
現在我的發文呢
只要圖片的,蠻喜歡從那個IG直接發
那IG直接發呢,他就會怎麼樣
他就會直接發到FB跟Tray
所以現在,各位呢也歡迎追蹤我的IG跟Tray
那Tray偶爾會發一些
因為大部分發的FB都會發到那Tray偶爾,不定時会发一些只有翠有的所以各位可以去追蹤一下我的翠好,等一下,先給各位看一下我的翠
各位先來追蹤一下我的翠在哪裡
等一下,我看一下我的翠
我看一下我的翠要怎麼找
翠在哪裡?我找一下
欸?
脆不是在我的那個
好
看到了
好,這就是我的脆啦
各位呢
可以追蹤一下
Warrant-LB
這個有一堆
綁帽的喔
那Warrant就是
Warrant
Warrant就是全鎮
LB呢就是
小哥
所以World-LB
這個就是我啦
目前呢有5.4萬位粉絲
這邊有
這個算是
聊得蠻多的
那翠這邊也會有一些酸民
這個我覺得發文都有一些酸民欸
很好玩欸
小娜殺成這樣台股開盤會受影響
你看發這邊文章
7點56分他是長這樣沒有錯啊
他其實他假如一直長這樣的話
台股顯然會被影響嘛
可是他後面拉上去了
後面拉上去了
好啦 就發這篇文
因為只是要告訴大家
為什麼要發這篇文
因為他是之前的延續啦
來來來
這是之前的延續
之前延續在這邊
這個原本禮拜四晚上
夜盤的 夜盤漲了800點
夜盤漲800點
那各位看一下這
富時台灣指數
這邊解釋一下
因為有的可能不大清楚
那富時台灣指數呢
在新加坡交易的
所以你要开海外期货才看得到
开海外期货你才看得到这个商品
你看到
你看看这边
这个是礼拜五的早上
礼拜五早上呢
它是延续着周四的盘
也就说呢
礼拜四晚上的夜盘
这个副值也大概涨了800点的位置
然后礼拜五早上呢
它就延续着开盘
它也是涨了快800点的位置
那為什麼說這裡是漲快800點 我教各位看喔
那-10的指數呢 大概是跟台灣的指數大概差11到12倍
差11到12倍啦所以呢你看這邊 4113到1804113到180這邊大概差了67
那67點你去把它乘以12好了
乘以12他大概700800點
這邊大概700800點
所以一開盤的700800點居然跌光
所以我說夜盤的800點跌光了
下次可以放假也開市嗎
因為假如放假我開市
那開盤一定是一個很好空的位置
就像今天一樣
今天呢開版是超級無敵好空
今天開版超級好空
今天開版就有那種感覺啦
覺得今天的盤應該是蠻大的行情
那我今天當充呢
當充這個期限我做起來
這個獲利還蠻不錯的
我有貼在那個儲置群裡面
我有貼在儲置群裡面
好 那個先給各位看
這邊呢是疊了這個
儲置群有看到吧
儲置群的應該看到
我還沒有公開貼
就貼在儲置群而已
各位呢你要看的話可以去儲置群裡面看得到
就是儲置的付費群
儲置的付費群
有看到的加個1一下
有看到的加個1
有沒有 有看到幫我加個1
在儲置的付費群裡面
那你就看到我有很多那個
我做很多標的
做很多標的
然後這個那些標的
那些標的都有他的原因啦
都有他的原因
我做的那些標的都有他的原因
其實蠻大的原因是因為儲置
是因為儲置喔
這個對呀 單日破千萬
單日破千萬
蠻大的原因是因為儲置造
儲置的一些下單的方法
所以呢 這儲置有沒有用
儲置太好用了啦
太好用了
這個凡是
凡是上過儲置的人都巴不得了怎麼樣
巴不得你不要再上了
不要再上了
好 那我們再來看
那結果呢 這是週四的
應該說這是週
週五早上
週五早上的盤
然後呢 開高
然後結果週五下午就在跌光
週五下午跌光
結果呢 到了下午跌光之後呢
我晚上又漲上去
晚上又漲上去
那我說 如果週末沒特殊狀況
週五應該還是會開高
還是會開高
所以这段话没有错
但周末呢也出了一点状况
对啊 看到我穿那个哆啦A梦服装所以各位 酸民是酸不倒我的啦我衣服多兜肯穿这个哆啦A夢你怎么可能酸得到我呢这个我的心理素质多么坚强
这个很难那个啦
很难酸得到我
好 那我们再看再看
那在周一早上呢
这个杀成这样嘛
所以他当然会有点影响
有可能会让那个
那个原本这个期待
周一期待开高的这个台股呢
有可能会到受到小纳影响呢
变成开
本来可以开个这个中高盘
可能会变成开个小高盘
结果呢
结果发文之后呢
这小纳后面往上走了嘛
往上走了
那台股呢就开的比较高一点
开比较高一点
好哇塞这篇引来了好多酸民了
呵呵为什么
因为
因为小纳杀成这样台股开盘会受影响的
这是我的发文嘛
那一堆酸民就來
來看一下 那個
這邊的 看一下
看一下這邊的酸民
這裡還好餒
每天都要這樣緊張嗎?不累嗎?
其實我沒有緊張啦 我沒有緊張
然後
沒事了 啥音響
笑死
好啦 所以這個
這個不是算名
那我們來看一下那個
那個我的FB
FB也是有一些算名
那我們來講一下那個
先來講一下這算名
這邊三千多個贊欸 哇塞
我現在那個發文的贊超多的
欸等一下等一下
我應該是看
喔對
欸這是今天下午的
我覺得大家對那個指數的盤呢
欸 蠻有樂趣的 蠻有興趣的
來來來
眾人皆醒你獨罪
眾人皆醒我獨罪
然後呢 再看一下
能封鎖 保爸保媽媽
這沒辦法 不是沒辦法
每天封真的是 封不勝封
發一篇文就是好幾個來
然後我們設關鍵字也沒有用
笑死
然后再看一下
有你们都一直赢钱
所以看不透金融市场
我写说对啊看不透没关系
赢钱就好
贏钱就好了 哇台股真的天下无敌
还好吧跟你说迟早会上去怎么一直看错了
一直看错
看不懂 怎么叫一直看错
然后韭菜
这么多留言你只有回封所三宝吧
那还好啦 那没什么
那我们再看一下 还有
中文接罪你独行
还有啊
有人问答看码丸子就是我刚刚跟各位讲的
这粉丝业不准退最终了
退了没 退了没
应该看人家退了没
1%叫迪恩坛
嗯 还好
你没三文我尊重你 还不错 还不错
要求小哥拍的错吗
还好啦 哈孝子被咖啡了
哦 就这样 哦 其实没有啦 其实我们只是在
只是在怎么样 只是在
跟各位讲 那个开盘看到的这个现象
看到这个现象而已
没有什么特别意义
小纳沙城这样台股开盘会受影响
就这样 好 那即便开盘是这样子的
那我们还是去做一件事啊
盘前抽抽的
盘前抽抽的 那什么叫盘前抽抽的呢
其实我们看到小纳沙城这样
那台股開盤會受影響
結果那個
早上去看那個期貨的期貨盤
發現期貨盤蠻強的
一堆股期漲停板嘛
那其中聯電就漲停板
那聯電漲停板呢
我就去抽抽熱了
我就去掛聯電
我就掛聯電漲停板
那我掛了大概
我掛了幾筆
可能有100筆吧
應該沒有100筆
我算一下
可能四五十筆
我還沒有掛很多
这个我还没有挂很多我挂了四五十笔
那中了一笔
中了一笔
各位看一下成交11张要160块
那在中的当下
跟各位讲
这个是一个每个
在中的当下我就把单子全部删掉了
为什么因为在那边挂的单子不应该
不应该成交了就只有第一盘
第一盘可以让他成交后面都不应该成交
后面成交代表出事了
阿伯出事了後面成交就是出事的意思好啦那我現在呢給各位看一下那一筆呢後面的狀況怎麼樣
來我現在用那個desk in
我來連線一下
我先連線desk in
連到我的手機
啊
這個我連到我的手機一下
啊開始直播對
然後呢這邊呢這裡這裡
這裡好給各位看
這就是聯電啊聯電我們11張嘛
11張就我今天我就一開盤
開盤賣在開盤
所以我是買在開盤賣在開盤
有沒有看到
買在開盤賣在開盤
今天應該是賣開盤
這個就是一個抽抽樂
抽抽樂當然有他的美甲在
那美甲我們在之前的上課有講過
我這邊就不要講
這邊有沒有
買在開盤賣在開盤
我賣在173
就賣在開盤
那我昨天去抽啊
所以去抽
然后呢我就卖债开盘
你看光这么简单的一个交易呢
就赚钱了对不对
是不是够简单
很简单吗
这个买债开盘卖债开盘
还有人说联电我看到哪里
我没有看好不好
我隔天就卖掉了
我看什么看
根本不用看好不好
这个根本不用看
根本不用看
直接
直接开盘卖掉就好
没有涨停就卖掉
我的邏輯很簡單
我假如去買漲停的
沒有漲停就賣掉
再講一次喔
去買漲停的沒有漲停就賣掉
那這個是今天
一開盤賣的連電
所以即便我們看到了這個
我們再跟各位講
我看到這東西
我認為台股會受影響
所以心裡要有點準備
因為小娜有在殺
有在殺 所以台股
這個受到影響
抽抽了什麼意思
開盤的低盤是抽的啊各位 開盤低盤是抽籤中的你看一下 你看一下昨天昨天開盤低盤這裡
昨天開盤低盤這個是
呃 這個是
這不是那麼好中的耶
各位啊 這不是那麼好中的
17000張
事實上呢 在開盤前
我記得不只這麼少
不只這麼少
所以呢他是掛單的人中了一萬七千張
再講一次喔
掛單的人中了一萬七千張
所以呢
呃你只有第一盤有機會
後面都是什麼
後面都是
喔
理論上後面都是別人中的
喔看一下
喔
我昨天這麼噴噹
我來看一下喔
這個
昨天
哇國票盾備吧
這都是那個去玩的
這邊你看
這邊都誰中
這都是101啊
這101中的
我以前有問他過啊
都你們中都不用玩
沒有小哥我們這個
我們一個月要花多少成本在上面
一個月花多少成本在上面
各位 這個是全部都他種的
這個全部都他種的
從一萬七千張以後都他
都他
你買不到啦
一萬七千張以後都沒有
除非他倒出來
喔 開牌一百多萬張我一買喔
天哪 一百多萬張我中十一張欸
開牌是一百多萬張欸
我中十一張 不錯了啦
不錯了對不對
他昨天不要三單
不要三單
不要三單會買到嗎
應該不會買到啦
應該不會買到
因為
因為我
我是掛在漲停板
我不是掛市價單啊
這從這一筆之後都是市價單
都市價單成交啦
所以呢
我假如昨天我掛著
我不一定會成交
假如有成交到的事情
為什麼
因為市價已經全部成交完了
然後又換成漲停板成交
反正這個是抽抽了啦
100多萬張嘛
我中11張
不錯
隔天開高賣掉
所以我們看到了這個東西是個現象
看到了小納碟是個現象
那開判我們還是按照那個按照作單方法做啊盤錢抽抽的 該抽的也是抽啦看那三寶爸的筆記 家破人亡這個三寶爸真的很煩 好不好
跟你講 真的很煩
一堆三寶爸 煩死了
但是我們怎麼封鎖也沒用
怎麼封鎖也沒用
他每天都用
現在三寶爸寫你長得睜眼 妻力止善
三寶爸每天去各地方去留言
哦那我昨天是11张11张挂
我没有一次挂全部
好啦
所以中了刚好中了11张
这是第一个
我还没认挂啦
其实我认真挂一点
应该可以中比较多张
哦这是昨天的
哦那跟我讲一下
哇现在这个
诶这个
诈骗很坏
这是真实我的萃
这是真的我的萃
只有这一个是真的
这一行是真的
底下这是P图
P2
這個這樣是真的
底下是P2
所以呢反正什麼領取基歐股
那個都騙人的啦
所以呢各位看到這種
都是騙人的不要被騙了
好那這個是
這是昨天的狀況
這是今天下午夜盤的狀況
夜盤很刺激喔
跌了1300點
所以呢各位你要知道一個東西啊
來給各位看一個東西
這個我覺得比較恐怖的一點
來
給各位看一下齁 我們來看一下60分線
60分線現在長這樣
欸
等一下
我給各位看一下60分線
現在60分線我是覺得看起來蠻恐怖的
蠻恐怖的
60分線蠻恐怖的
欸 等一下
欸
等等 我的這個同意
好 各位呢 你看一下60分線喔 現在長這樣
現在的60分K
現在60分K
所以它從49000已經跌到46000
它短短的
短短的
短短不到24小時啊
各位
不到24小時呢 它已經跌了快3000點
相當於7.5% 有沒有
相當於這個跌了3000點
嗯
6%來 6%
我們從這邊算6%
相當於快6% 所以
所以齁
我這次這個回檔齁
這個有點狠
有點狠齁
所以各位呢 你現在手上的部位呢
要小心齁 你假如
再跟各位講齁 你假如有開槓桿的話
如果有開槓桿的話
各位你要記得一件事情
有開槓桿的話
你不能全部的部位都是
都是那個多單
那會很危險
有開槓桿不能全部都多單
你沒有開槓桿你全部多單我沒有意見
好不好沒有意見
你all in多OK的OK的
你沒有開槓桿沒差
那你有開槓桿呢你不能全部都多單
因為你全部多單呢
你看台子期一下子回檔了6%
那有些股票呢 揮檔個十幾% 那很容易啊
那很容易
所以呢 他今天呢 就是我們
我們這個
最好做的盤
其實我們
盤中呢 都會做點短空
那今天呢 算是 極好做的盤
首先 來看一下
友達
友達 各位看一下
這邊拉高空 殺低谷
這個我今天做的非常大
量做很大
哇這小菜有什麼 看一下小菜
哇賽 小菜不好好帶團
這個各位有興趣參加他的旅遊
去看一下他是不是帶團的時候都在打單
是不是都在打單 怎麼玩那麼大
好 來來來來 那個
我們呢 今天好給你看 這是我今天我的下單
你看很刺激喔 密密麻麻喔
那從這邊看過來這什麼東西
這叫群創期貨
群創期貨
我光群創期貨
我群創期貨這樣子下
這樣子下呢
各位你看一下
它來回大概就有
來回有這個6000口
群創期貨來回有6000口
然後群創的現股呢
來回有這個大概4000張
群創期貨有6000口群創現股有4000張那這個67塊的這邊我砍了1筆499我丟了1筆499下去了就是把它擊潰
67塊把它擊潰
我還蠻喜歡去擊潰那個關鍵卡
關鍵價啦
關鍵價
擊潰關鍵價
這個多巴胺分泌蠻多的
把它擊潰
看它後面的反應怎麼樣
那左邊掛號呢
就是左邊成交的贓數
右边挂的就是右边成交账数
所以呢我们这个量呢是做的非常非常大
好 有没有
这边量做的非常非常大
这个就是
啊 那起货的话一个TICK就赚钱
起货的话一个TICK就赚钱
这个TICK就是
呃 这个TICK是200块
好 一个TICK是200块
好 那我做了
大概3000口嘛
好 那3000口呢
我今天的这个群创我看一下
這是我群創的對張單
群創對張單這邊
這裡
來
這是我今天的群創對張單在這裡
群創期貨呢2960口
2960對不對 2960
我點位都給你看了
2960嗎
然後我留空單
期貨我留空單
然後現貨留多單
先握留多單 看得出來嗎
期握留空單 先握留多單嗎
那我先握最終一課的成交價是66塊
我最後一課我花了
花了大概600多張
我花了600多張 然後呢去買
我去買66.2
我希望他進儲置
我花了600多張 希望他進儲置
結果他沒進
這個因為不想讓他進儲置的人太多了
我是希望他進儲置啊
所以呢各位看一下
600多張也700多張吧
你看一下最後一筆
最後一筆這個
這是大家來PK
來決鬥你知道嗎
這邊在決鬥
這個是沒有關
這個是被關
這是沒關
這是被關
有沒有看到
大家呢來砸這個價格
那他价格
这边的人呢
这边的人
成交66块成交66块没关成交66.1被关我是希望他被關啊所以我花了600多張砸外盤
沒用 沒用沒差 為什麼沒差
這對我來講沒有差啊
各位看一下
為什麼沒差
我有空單啊 我有多單嘛
我丟了之後我就變多單嘛
我丟了之後變多單
這個
繳進去了沒關係啊 我這邊是空單
進去我這邊是空單
那沒進去的話呢
我這邊是多單
然後呢
一進去之後呢
這個一確定沒進去之後
哇塞 那個期貨往上噴啊
這邊期貨往上噴
給各位看那個3481
3481期貨的狀況
沒進之後呢
一路往上衝
等他衝到梅里我去空他
再把他空下來
這個是今天的狀況
這裡啊
有沒有
這邊是沒有進處置之後
66塊喔
確定沒有關
這邊確定沒關
確定沒關發生什麼事啊
你看這邊這好變態啊
這66.1的上面是68.5啊
這什麼鬼啊
上面價格都空了
大家都去
大家都不掛66.2.3.4.5
大家都掛66.1
然後呢
這個自從1.5以後
大家來看一下
這1.5以後發生什麼事
哇這可精彩啦
這裡
1.5
1.5從67.86T-9
這邊
一確定
確定那個
我看一下他原本是大概在這個位置
六七點大概這個位置
確定沒有關之後呢一路往上衝有沒有
這邊就是確定沒關之後
哇
可能是
這個有人空他然後堵他被關嘛
結果沒被關立馬
反手停損
反手停損整個被往上拉
那這邊看起來就覺得價差太大了嘛
我說這邊為什麼很簡單啊
我空這邊我去買盤後都划算
我空這位置買盤後都划算
因為這邊差了3塊錢只是你沒辦法確定你盤後可以買好幾張好啦 反正這個是一個蠻精彩的一個工房主力工房站
大家在工什麼
這個有兩派人
一派是要這個要被關的
我是站在希望他被關的這個那一派
因為被關才好玩
各位群眾被關才好玩好不好
他才會讓紙回頭啊
對不對 背關才會讓紙回頭嘛
這個沒多少錢啦 各位
群創的
鼓棋沒多少啦
這裡齁 大家看一下齁 群創的
鼓棋的保證金是21000啊
21000嘛
那我是來回刷啦 我今天是
這個群創我是來回刷
這邊刷了
3000 不是 我不是同時間有3000口
沒有啦
我最大大概是500口
我最大是500口 我這樣來回刷
來回刷 那你看這個來回刷
來回刷其實刷起來
刷起來蠻驚人的啦
我是覺得
刷起來那個
那個獲利蠻驚人的
那不只群創
我們有打現
不只打期貨啦 也有打現股
所以群創是兩邊做
你看這現股
這個平均大概是算2000張
2000張然後66塊
所以光現股就打了2億多
群創光現股就打了2億多
那這些呢都是怎麼樣
都是
都是你
平常你再去看那個
這個從
從你下單的盤桿
就是我們這個蠻常下單的嘛
還有從全方位的訊號
今天全方位訊號呢
一開盤呢就是蠻偏空的
這一開盤蠻偏空的
這邊啊這邊會有全方位的訊號
那另外呢還會從這個正利價差比
正利價差比會看什麼
假如全部都正利價差比呢
代表這個盤是非常非常多
超級多
那今天的盤中看到其實有很多都變成逆價差
那代表說這個盤已經快要變了
這盤已經快要變了
這盤快要變了
所以我看看我有一個比較多的
什麼的
其實我沒有一個比較多的
我沒有一個比較多的
所以我沒有一個比較多的
我覺得我覺得
逆價差很多 很多%很高的話
那這盤就很容易上去
當逆價差很多%差很高的話
那這盤就容易下去
因為期貨呢 是
期貨是那個領先指標
所以呢 我們會從這邊看
全方位這裡面東西才太多 太好用了
太好用了 我們盤中一定是開這個軟體
開這個軟體看
那我們盤中會看很多東西啊
所以呢 我看這麼多東西
然後呢 我交易這麼大
嗯 在跟我講 我看這麼多東西嘛
然後我交易這麼大
我利用了什麼東西做交易呢
我利用了全方位
那我再利用了這個當充神器
當充神器很重要
因為當充神器我們就可以去抓轉折
所以呢 各位你現在看到的那個群創跟友達
其實我都是利用當充神器去抓轉折
去抓轉折
去抓那個連次連亮
各位有看到 這邊我們都是連次連亮排序
今天是禮拜二嘛
禮拜二
這個群創
38月群創
這邊
連次連亮排序
我們會用連次連亮排序
然後 這是我看的這個順序
那我們在利用處置事件
我們看的東西是非常非常
非常的細
看的無敵細
那個
納斯達克的早盤
那个只是其中的一点东西而已
所以呢 你假如说
我看那斯达克早盘 我决定了什么
你未免把我想的太肤浅
我没有那么肤浅
好不好 我没有那么肤浅
我们盘中看的是很多很多的面向
盘中看的很多面向
因为你盘中没看那么多面向
你的胜率不会那么高啊
你盘中要看很多面向 你的胜率才会高
才高啦
那我們盤中看很多面向
你看
我今天做的這個友達隔日補蝶
做的這個群創
群創跟著友達一起打
那光群創友達
齊現貨呢
就幫我賺了大概700萬
700萬
你看我們看這麼多東西
然後看這麼多東西呢
結果你這個
酸民呢酸民他就
好不容易逮到你
逮到你喔呦 小哥你是個大肉腳喔 有沒有老實好不容易逮到你喔你看 你認為小納殺你就覺得台股會殺結果台股沒殺
其實大部分小納殺10次
台股他還殺8次
他就拿了其中一項
其中一天台股沒殺
啊 小哥 反指標
反指標大師
有沒有看到
小哥 反指標大師
然後我說嗯好吧
你要這樣講我也無所謂
哈哈
我也不會封鎖你啊
我也不需要封鎖你
因為我是覺得
你把我想的太膚淺
喔
我又不是看到這樣子
我就去決定我當年的交易
對不對
我們是會看訊號
所以跟各位講
訊號非常重要
喔
好啦
就這樣齁 所以算名是這樣
反指標大師
這個反指標大師還蠻
這邊還有
這邊
反指標大師
南板巴利利
哇 南板巴利利要出現了吧
哇塞 說我南板巴利利
哇塞
這個是太推崇我了
那你說我是反指標大師呢
那我們來看一下今天的對賬單
這個
因為說我反指標大致
那我們可以看一下
這個對賬單
來
因為今天我有貼在那個
社群上
這要當
要當反指標也沒那麼容易
來 拍檔
這裡面呢就有一檔彩金培
所以呢你要當反指標
你必須要
這裡面是有多有空
例如說可成是多
那全創是空
邀達是空
台子期是多
台子期是空
台光電是空
台勝客是空
這裡這個進處制
這個進處制
台勝客進處制
信倉電進處制
環球金進處制
彩晶是前兩天空的
他是我的避險單
那亞光呢是明天除息華新科呢是明天盡處置可成是一項以來的多單群創呢是玩聽牌策略
華碩呢是準備處期
友達呢是跟群創一起玩
我今天是友達沒有一起玩
其實友達應該要玩得更多一點
所以我們這邊滿滿的東西
我們滿滿的數字
滿滿的股票
我都可以告訴你說
我為什麼做這一檔
有沒有
你看我從頭到尾 我沒跟你講說
我憑感覺
沒有 我完全沒有憑感覺 好不好
我全部都可以告訴你說 我為什麼做這檔股票
為什麼做這檔股票
你看這合金做得很漂亮喔
合金今天做得很漂亮
因為合金呢 它也是一個
它也是在一個近牌的邊緣
這個聽牌的邊緣 不是
聽牌的邊緣在那邊混
所以呢 這些
每個這些邏輯
我們都會在處置課教給你
各位 禮拜四又有處置課了
還沒報名的趕快去報名
這次報名的人非常多
那個
我們禮拜四處置課呢
我就講我最近的一些教育策略
反正我們每次講都講最近的
你 成幾何時
你看我去講一個很久很久以前的案例
沒有 我講的都是一個超級無極定的
你想說我是一個反指標
那我反指標
那我應該是一堆賠錢 對不對
好
這是其貨
我們來看一下今天的現貨
現貨在這邊
這是今天的現貨
那現貨呢
立正被關了
友達嘛 友達群創
這個就是友達是隔日補碟
那群創呢 他今天有機會被關
光潔被關了
齁 齊邦是我的多單
我的多單喔
我的多單 然後開高我賣掉
開高我賣掉
合金呢 它也是一個那個
那個 合金也是一個
聽牌的股票 正發呢 浪子回頭
有沒有看到 我所有的標的
我都告訴你為什麼 有沒有
然後呢 這邊700加300
1000 有沒有 加起來1000
我都告訴你 我為什麼這麼做
你看我們現在做
做單是不是做的有理有據
有理有據 對不對
我做單全部都是用邏輯好不好
全部邏輯
看得很細 用邏輯那個點位抓得很好然後呢 用連次量去抓轉折抓轉折轉折都讓你看了好不好轉折就在這邊
轉折很多啦 今天有一堆轉折
這邊...這裡...轉折
這邊是我的轉折點
都給你看
有沒有看到
全部都讓你看了 方法也教了
那很多人跟我們是做同一個標的
方法也一樣
點位也一樣
獲利的方法也一樣
什麼都一樣
然後你跟我說
我是藍版巴利膩
好啦 無所謂
我無所謂
你說我藍版巴利膩
我就是巴利膩了
我就巴利膩了
欸 什麼東西
有個粉絲周縣我不認識他
喔 好啦 好啦
來來 這個
這個請各位加一下這個啦
這個全政小哥的討論群
喔 全政小哥的討論群
喔 欸哇 看一下
好像蠻嚴重的
把它拿出來給各位看一下
看一下
我不知道這個是真的假的啦
反正有人講嘛
他說
有個粉絲周獻庭
然後這個騙了11個
我不知道李治郎這句話真的假的啦
我不知道
反正呢就是
你不要被騙啦
所以各位呢
那個
人家叫你拿錢出來
你就不要拿嘛
對不對
好不好
人家叫你拿錢出來
要代操什麼都不要
好不好
自己做
自己學自己做
好不好
所以
不要再洗了
我沒看到了
我也不曉得你說的
真的假的
我對這件事情
我不要評論
我不曉得
搞不好周憲亭也是受害者
我也不知道
我不知道到底誰受害了
因為你這樣貼我哪知道
沒評沒趣的
但是呢
假如有這種類似事件
這種類似事件我們只能跟各位講說
你不要被人家帶吵好不好
不要被人家帶吵
粉絲怎麼樣關我命死
對 我也真的
你們假如有
有一天看到有一個人跟我拍照
然後他幹了什麼壞事
你把他來追究在我身上
我也沒辦法好不好
每天來照拍照的那麼多
我總不能先做身家調查
調查完之後好吧 我讓你拍個照
不可能
所以這個
沒辦法
好
這麼好騙要不要考慮不要做股票
很好
這個每次呢
每次我們都會講這句話
這麼好騙要不要考慮不要做股票
沒有錯
對對對
所以各位不要被騙
好啦
這個
那也歡迎加我們的討論群
討論群呢
密碼四個八
有實戰復盤資訊分享
還有解剖專區啦
上面就有了
好
這邊
然后呢这个直播注意事项啊
各位看一下
那我们来看上周中奖名单啊
去年上了除席课
一定要把学位赚回来
今年6月底上现账课立马报名
刚好赶上忘记
期待小伙对今年除原期的看法和操作细节
呃
今年除原期跟去年有点类似
这个我们做了几个标的还不错
算获利满不错的
好
那去年投资
你曾经怀疑自己是否适合
曾经一度想放递投资
那时间心情低落
結果努力好像都沒有回報
努力沒有回報是這樣子的啦
你假如努力呢
你都在努力一些很奇怪的東西喔
那會真的是
那那種回報真的是有點
有點
有點慘啦
舉例來說啦
假設你今天要做短線好了
你今天要做短線
你今天要做群創好了
群創你今天到底是要做多還是做空
你從MACD來看
怎麼看都是要做多嘛
怎麼看都是要做多對不對
喔 有沒有
有沒有看到 群創人怎麼看都要做多
假如你用MACD來看啊
我用MACD 然後你被做群創當充
那你就不曉得 我真的不曉得你在做什麼東西啊
不知道你在做什麼啊
你懂嗎
你假如看MACD 然後做這些
那可是坊間呢 很多人喔
這個 以前有人開MACD課 一開25萬
你在玩短線 然後你看MACD
然後看NCD 看這個點位
那就代表說 你可能用錯方法了好不好那其實呢 我覺得 你用籌碼用事件
在我們的短線交易裡面 用籌碼用事件
用連次量抓轉折
所以呢 我們是做的巨細米
我們連統計都用上了
好不好
處置的統計告訴你
處置的事件告訴你
廉次亮他也是個統計
他把那個
成交明細
原本是足筆戳合的
我們把它變慢來看
你就可以看得出來它的轉折
那當
當今天那個盤適合你的話
像今天盤就很適合我們這樣做
因為今天是大AK盤就很適合
那我們平常做呢
小賺小賺小賺
在大AK那一天呢
會大賺爆賺
狂賺
大黑K的那一天呢
會爆賺狂賺
那這些呢都是
用事件來做
那你去用這種指標
你會不知道怎麼做
所以有時候怎麼樣
有時候是
大家問題是怎樣
你努力的時候
你可能努力錯的方向
你可能看到一本
連作者自己也不曉得他在寫什麼的書
再跟各位講一次
那坊間一堆書都是抄來抄去的好不好
坊間的一堆書都抄來抄去的
連作者也不曉得他自己在寫什麼
因為他也是用抄的
他也沒在下單嘛 他什麼一山也都不知道
他什麼都不知道
連寫的都不知道他在寫什麼
你還拿來看
你看了之後呢 你也不曉得你在看什麼
然後呢 你拿去做
做人到底會不會賺錢
你的賺錢全部都是亂數 好不好
再講一次 你的賺錢會不會賺都是亂數
都是靠運氣決定
那我們的賺錢呢
我們賺錢就是靠什麼
我們賺錢靠的是統計
靠的是機率
靠的是這個事件
我們讓自己呢
是一個高勝率的玩家
高勝率的玩家
你懂嗎
所以我很不大喜歡去賭場
因為賭場 我的勝率再怎麼樣
我都比不上我在股市裡面的勝率嘛對不對 我當然喜歡在股市裡面玩就好了所以不愛去賭場去賭場玩幾下就滿無聊的因為我哪看得出來啊我哪看得出來那個紅黑紅黑
我哪看得出來 對不對
那你看我們今天友達為什麼做這麼大
因為友達這個很明顯嘛
你看 各位看一下
友達這個連三紅吧 對不對
啊連三紅
昨天群創是黑
啊友達跟群創的
啊群創黑
啊友達紅
啊這就是什麼
這就是
對不對這就是什麼
喔
隔日補蝶谷嘛
有沒有看到
這有加不
有沒有叫
有學過的加個1好不好
有學過加個1
再講一次
友達這叫隔日補蝶谷嘛
這以前我們放空課什麼課
一堆課都教過
這叫隔日捕蝶谷嘛 對不對
友達所漲停 群創黑
那明天不砍友達砍誰啊 你懂嗎
明天不砍友達砍誰
然後呢
然後一堆人
友達
紅山兵欸
這叫紅山兵欸
MACD開布林
今天友達怎麼樣
就是要往上攻了嘛
要開布林往上衝了
我們今天就是買友達
買完友達怎麼樣
買友達
我們未看先猜
我還沒有看今天的籌碼
我猜國泰敦南又有買
未看先猜好不好
國泰敦南有買
看一下
看是不是國泰敦南
欸 賭名
國泰敦南還要賭名
未看先猜
我也看先猜國泰敦蘭買
快蛋的肉咖嘛 對不對 肉絞
對不對 我們教的方法
教過很多次 那個早就
判斷在事前
友達吃這個就好
好不好
國泰敦蘭
這3萬人不來上課
不來上課
每次做單憑感覺
原本要做當沖
結果怎麼樣
原本友達今天是要做當沖
衝啊
套啊
有什麼
衝啊
要再攻漲停啊
套啊等一下 沒關係我們不是做價差的我們們做存股的好不好國外的來就做存股了那國泰台中是誰
這叫國泰
國泰就是散戶
散戶台北分點
國泰散戶台北分點
國泰散戶台中分點
星光散戶台北分點
這幾個啊
這幾個
喔 這邊啊 這邊啊 剛好前三分點
噢
敦蘭人是無辜的
沒有啦 阿 阿 阿 阿 阿 阿 阿 阿 阿 阿 阿 阿 阿 阿 阿
每次黑黑都是他 那他會不會解套 他有可能會解套啦
說真的 有達有可能會解套啊 但是
總有一天他沒辦法解套
總有一天 那個最高點就他買了
喔 中午一天
我不曉得是哪一天
喔 我不曉得是哪一天
總有一天啦 喔 你看 你看一下這邊
這邊
喔 這邊應該也有他
來看一下 看一下 看一下這天有沒有他
5月26 唉唷
那我看一下
喔 5月26號應該也有他啦
反正那個
那個
子要怎麼樣
你看果然有他嘛 對不對
哎呀 解套 解套 解套 有沒有
解套了
你看這大買對不對
然後解套 喔 解套立馬大賣
解套你也打不開嘛
每個都這樣嘛 對不對
他的解套啦
他
十次有九次的解套
最多次也不會
十次有九次解套 最後一次不會
最後一次不會 那最後一次可能就套
套很久了
啊 股票都這樣
所以
這些邏輯策略方法
我們都有在教
我也做給各位看
也做給各位看
所以呢 你懂這些方法
你就知道說怎麼樣
你就知道說
今天狗達是要做空的啦
對不對
所以你看喔
直到用了全證小哥的組織APP
才發現原來很多虧損
不是因為能力不足
不是你能力的問題啊
我每次上課都跟學員講
我現在教的全部都是
加減
頂多用到乘除就可以解決的
我連開根號都沒有用
再跟各位講
用開根號都沒有用到開根號
我們甚至連什麼SinCita CosinCita
各位你都忘記了
這個完全不會用
那我什麼幾何都沒用到
我們只用到加減乘除
我教的一切東西
只要你
國小畢業
甚至你國小沒有畢業你都聽得懂啊
甚至你國小沒有畢業你都聽得懂
好不好我們教的東西都很簡單
簡單的邏輯判斷而已
所以你看他寫得很好
而是因為沒有人教過正確的方法跟觀念
這一路跟著學習
學會了控制風險管理情緒
更重要是重新找回對未來的信心
謝謝全職小哥不只是分享投資
是更在許多人迷惘的時候
給予繼續前進的力量
市場有漲有跌
但這份正向的影響力永遠都是破例
真的
呵呵呵
喔 你看
對 真的啦
好了
想抽米其娃娃也大推小哥組織
好 恭喜你種米其娃娃
喔 再私訊你的那個
你的全家
全家電子
電話我們再寄給你
好啦
這是那個
這個
中獎的
那我們來看一下近期的學員戰機
學員戰機在這裡
最近的學員戰機
精彩滑邦店
富邦美 富邦美 我有做
好
唉唷 這個隊長在之前呢
還沒改
好啦 那我們來講一下
今天要特別講一下
看對股票卻賠錢 全證新手最容易踩的坑
還是講一下
那這邊呢 要講一個東西啊
首先呢 全證呢 他有
他有一個東西叫
那個 隱含波動率
那什麼叫隱含波動率齁
我們再來看一下權政
因為很多人喜歡玩權政
在這種時代
其實權政也沒有說
但是比以前爛
我們那個年代的權政真的很好
2009年的權政真的很讚
但現在的權政呢
可能就沒那麼好
那全證呢 我們上次有講過了
你要記得 不要找那個心思比例 0.01的
那這個呢 你會在除期的那個時候會被吃豆腐那專門吃豆腐的人叫做誰 叫做統一統一真的很壞這個行事比例給你用0.001那0.001在做出席的時候會做調整
那調整呢 他會從0.001
調整變成0.0011
或12或13或14
不管1多少
1121314 全部425路
全部都沒去
所以呢 在除息的時候呢
你買統一的就先吃了一個虧
再講一次喔
除息的時候你買統一先吃一個虧
然後呢他還會從什麼地方搞你
還會從什麼地方搞你
這就厲害了
他會從什麼地方搞你呢
他會從影韓波動力搞你
從影韓波動力搞你啊
來來來來
我們舉例我們來看一個這個
你看這個
哇 你看這影韓波動力 一路往下
那影韓波動力往下
這個這個 因為剛上市
剛上市跌不多 那影韓波動力呢
假如一路往下的話 會有什麼影響
那我這邊呢 用一個068005呢
來給各位這個做個
示範
068005 來來來來
我們來看一下
我找一個元大權政王
好
這邊
來
068.005
來這邊齁 我們用統一為例
那統一呢這一檔齁
這個我們講一下
他的 呃先來看他的履約價
履約價是3300
那現在的
那現在統一齁
現在台積電的股價才2500
2500而已
昨天那個
有一篇文章啊
喔 說什麼
台積電有人在2500打了525252
喔 我找一下
我找一下一篇文章一下
喔 說打了什麼5252
我愛 我愛 我愛
這是什麼意思呢
說有這個投資人怎樣
說這個代表對投資人的愛意
然後呢
這個又有法人就說
啊這個是什麼
欸 黑打
我剛剛在跟各位講
你凡是看到一排的齁
再跟各位講
你凡是看到一排數字的齁
昨天台積電那個5252是幾點找一下 因天昨天有人跟我講怎樣
我找一下
昨天有人
他說這篇文章
告白台積電
神秘大單曝光
年36筆買52
買52
專家曝氏他進場
欸 曝是誰
是 我想說哇塞
這買52還會被人家知道是誰
喔 啊這種
只要同一個時間買52張
同一個時間買很多張
不管是那個487啊
478啊 520
不能520喔 因為不能超過499
或52的這種
凡是同時間可以打那麼多張的
跟各位講 那都是短線客
那短線客就是一個字
渣
什麼叫渣呢
他就是買了之後你以為他很愛他
他呢
好一點的渣
還陪你過夜
這給我講
好一點的渣
還陪你過夜
這壞一點的渣怎麼樣
一下就賣掉好不好
有沒有看到
這裡齁
所以呢有人說齁這個
52呢是520我愛你
不排除向台信堅告白的可能性
然後我跟講說
從盤中結構來看呢
明顯屬於高度紀律化
高度紀律化
這紀律化
這不是紀律啊
這只是
速度單而已啦
並非一般
產物追降具備策略性的主力
策略性的主力
對對對
或是大型法人進場布局
沒有啦
這反正你看到那個數字喔
例如說你盤中看到一堆499
幾乎待會都會到
要嘛鎖漲停
要嘛待會到貨
再跟各位講
凡是你盤中看到一堆499
要嘛今天想鎖漲停
要嘛待會到貨
逐步降股價推價關鍵加回
最終成功帶動股價創高支2510
對市場性行程強力示範效果
好
結果是誰你知道嗎
我們知道是誰啊
我們知道是誰
那個講了老半天你知道是誰嗎
你不知道 但我知道是誰
我知道是誰
昨天呢 有能力這個買5252他買在2500嘛所以呢首先他要先買2500買很多張嘛
對不對
啊2500可以買很多張的呢
呃各位啊
你52還可以打那麼多筆
然後呢可以買那麼多張的
就只有誰呢
我們來看一下
就只有誰
就只有他
摩根大通
好不好
你以為他買5252
我愛你喔
然後把台積電推到高點
有的沒的喔
那個要怎麼樣
要跟台積電這個
要抱很久
沒有
好不好
渣
買2500
倒一次
2510倒一次
渣
有沒有
倒掉了
到了
所以呢
這個
所以我就說這個台股呢
就有人有記者來問我啦
有記者來問我說這是誰啊
我說短線客啦
短線客
這個法人不會這樣玩啊
都短線客好不好
這摩根大通他就是個短線客
他連當創都會做
摩根大通可能是以前短線客藏在外資裡面
所以跟各位講 這個當你看到
一排數字的
都是短線客
短線客就是渣 好不好
就是短
短就是怎麼樣 要嘛待會沖掉
要嘛明天沖掉
就這麼簡單
好
再來喔 為什麼講到那邊
剛剛這邊
來來來
來看一下
這個統一呢這一檔喔
他現在
他的
履約價3300
那現在跟
3300呢
他是沒辦法履約的喔
所以呢他現在叫做價外
可以履約叫價內
不能履約叫價外
他是個價外的權政
而且價外很遠喔
欸這2500離3300是很遠的啊
你
你現在旅約價要3300點
那個股價要3300
那個各位啊 那台股要幾點
你有沒有想過這個問題 現在2500
2500塊的台積電
台股快5萬點了
3300塊的台積電
台股不就要6萬多點
然後隱含波動率搞一個99
你把它拜託欸 對不對
台積電的隱含波動率
歷史波動率才29
然後你要賣99
有沒有搞錯
有沒有搞錯 你要賣99
欸
來來來 我們從X槓比比較穩定
來 元大
人家元大名門正派
才賣43
隱含波動力賣43
你統一賣99
99什麼意思啊
就是他的權證就賣的特別貴
那賣的貴你要有保障啊
什麼叫保障
就是你賣的貴
你LV賣的貴
那你說元大賣那便宜
你是不是老皮蛋啊
人家統一賣的是什麼
人家統一賣的是LV
對不對
你元大難道賣的是LP嗎
對不對 你為什麼賣那麼便宜
對不對 你為什麼
隱藏波動率賣40幾
結果
欸
元大隱藏波動率賣40幾
但是元大怎麼樣
我們剛看的那個
欸 等一下 看一下喔
這個
剛看的元大隱藏波動率喔
來來
這邊喔
來 這邊有賣50幾的
然後呢
統一 我們看一下
這邊
哎呦這個
賣70幾
這裡
欸我的
元大剛賣40幾的跑去哪裡
我們從這裡找
這隱含波動率呢
隱含波動率我們要從這個
有報賣價的來看
等一下我把這個大於領
大約0
他可以把一些過濾掉
你看這隱含波動力喔
有報賣價的來看
有沒有看到這裡
統一他有賣很便宜的
但是他怎麼樣
他是從以前的48
後來剩下39
那
這個隱含波動力呢
穩定一點會比較好
你看元大
他這個就很穩定
所以你的隱含波动率稳定呢代表说你对人家就是有保障嘛為你的隱含波動力不穩定會發生什麼狀況呢?來來
來給各位看一下
你這裡隱含波動力在99嘛對不對
那我們試算一下
那當有一天呢你的隱含波動力在往下掉的時候
你看啊
當99來到97
你的股價齁你的全身價格就從1.1來到1.07
那假如當99來到了多少
來到了剩下50怎麼辦
剛剛的1.1升0.44耶
所以呢
隱含波動力下降會導致全震價格下降
再講一次
所以你要買的是一個隱含波動力穩定
的券商
那現在呢
有的券商呢
它隱含波動力不穩定
不穩定就算了
你還賣那麼貴
不穩定還賣很貴
有沒有看到 你看這邊0.01
這個從行私比例先來先搞一次
行私比例0.01
這已經讓人家吃了暗虧
行私比例0.01吃了暗虧
然後呢隱含波動域還用很高
那用很高之後呢還不穩定
有沒有看到 你看這邊
你看這隱含波動域原本從87
喔 現在掉到81
不穩定
只要賣出去越多
可能就越不穩定
哇塞 你看這裡
賣出去100%
原本79 現在剩68
有沒有
賣出去很多 全賣出去了
隱藍波動率就拼命往下掉
這個就是導致怎麼樣 這導致呢
看對股票卻賠錢
全政新手最容易踩的坑
就是你看對股票
你看對股票賠錢
賠錢啊
看對股票
就賠錢
你看這個052786我們來看一下
各位你看一下台縣長這樣
來看052786長怎樣
長這樣
然後呢
你假如找到那個
你找到那個價外的
你找到價外的
然後呢快到期的
然後隱含包裝就這樣一直掉
你會發現呢
你買錢證喔會非常非常的吃虧再講一次喔你假如買到那個價外的
我們看喔 這個因為台階漲上來
你假如買到那個比較價外的
然後快到期了
來來來 我們看一下
假如有價外的 然後天數比較短
因為台階他後面是一直漲
遇到一個這麼大的行情
那一假如呢這個
找到一個這個
我們來看一下
天數
添加條件
天數呢
我們找那個天數比較短的
小50天好了
小50天
然後呢 這種價外的
哇 那他有的後面呢 就有點恐怖喔
喔 假如 後面
哇 看一下
這邊 我這邊一堆價內了
假如 那種價外的 然後又快要到期了
他有的後面呢 他那個
那個時間價值呢 會掉的很快
時間價值掉很快 那現在
現在
這個
到了价内,你掉隐含波动率
可能对它的股价影响会没那么大
但是你假是价外的话,影响就会很大
所以我们从这边看
这边啊
像这种是价外的
价外的
它的履约价是在3300的
那这种隐含波动率往下掉
它对股价的影响就会非常大
所以跟各位讲,你买全震
首先你不要去买那个很价外的
第二個你不要去買那個
隱含波動率不穩定了
你要買呢 就要買像這種元大
元大呢 它隱含波動率穩定
它有多穩定呢 它甚至呢
它甚至隱含波動率呢 造勢多少都跟你講
例如說 055007
這裡喔
來
我們看一下 台經店
台經店 這裡喔
元大造勢為買波動率42%
他連造勢 違買 波動率都告訴你
對不對 統一敢寫嗎
他們不敢寫啦 那我剛剛下他寫的還得了 他寫的他這些權證怎麼樣跟人家交代你懂嗎同一寫了之後我們剛剛那個
剛剛看到一堆
那個行資比例很低的
0.01的
0.001的
他寫了之後他的那個全證隱含波多
你看這個隱含波多元他怎麼交代
一路往下降怎麼交代
你沒辦法跟投資人交代嗎
你懂嗎
你不能寫說你的造勢波動率是什麼
我寫78
然後改天我改69
再改68
再改62
然後每天往下改
不可能嘛
你懂嗎
不可能這樣子的
所以呢
這個我還是欣賞元大這種
會把
會把那個造勢波動率寫上去的
那我不喜歡那種
它的隱含波動率一直往下掉的
因為隱含波動率一直往下掉
它就會讓投資人怎麼樣
就會讓投資人有可能看對股票賠錢
那看對股票賠錢 假如賠是時間價值
我覺得這個是公道
那假如賠的不只時間價值
你還有賠那個隱含波動力往下掉的那個
你看不到的東西 那個我覺得就
就太傷了
好啦
這以上呢 就跟各位講 權證新手
你要買權證 你一定要
一定要怎麼樣 一定要用挑選權證小幫手
然後呢 點一下看這個隱含波動力有沒有穩定
那假如屬於那種不穩定的券商
就盡量避開
好不好
不穩定的券商就盡量避開
凱基也不錯
小哥這樣講統一會不會生氣
會啦
大概沒多久又要來找我
我們就不喜歡人家這樣子往下掉
我可以講嘛 對不對
我可以講好不好
我說講那麼多 講兩句不行嗎
對不對
欸 我們平常
今天交易稅繳多少
今天做了6億欸
交易稅不知道繳多少 又繳了幾十萬了
你知道嗎 繳了幾十萬難道不能講兩句話嗎
對不對
好啦
所以那個 這個
這個權政就這樣子 所以
有時候真的覺得很煩
這權政這樣子
買來來去去的 你又
弄那麼多坑
不如玩股票期貨 有沒有
玩得多開心 對不對
2000口 3000口 你看多開心啊
來來回回 多開心 對不對
多開心 有沒有
多開心 對不對
你玩這個人
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:10:00 起〕